[Musik]
jetzt also doch nach der Verlängerung
der Atomkraftwerke setzt die
Bundesregierung jetzt aber auf braun und
Steinkohlekraftwerke die
Stromproduzenten kehren zurück ans Netz
reitet uns das vor dem Blackout für wir
besorgt auch Paypal und Tesla Gründer
Ellen Masken mit seinem Friedensplan für
die Ukraine sie merken viel zu
besprechen heute Abend bei viertel nach
acht mit diesen spannenden Gästen
Historiker Hubertus Knabe erblickt
glaubt Putin nicht Fürstin Gloria von
Thurn und Taxis sie sorgt sich um unser
Land und ich frage sie ist unser Land in
Gefahr die Antwort gibt es gleich
darüber möchten wir sprechen
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler und frei
wählerpolitiker Martin Luther ihnen
beschäftigt das wahlchaus in Berlin und
der Sozialmediziner und obdachlosenarms
Gerhard Trabert erfordert Umverteilung
jetzt sie merken wir haben viel Debatten
Sprengstoff heute Abend bei viertel nach
acht Streit wollen wir ja auch gar nicht
vermeiden mich hat heute die
Pressekonferenz unseres
Wirtschaftsministers Robert Habeck
bewegt hören wir doch einmal rein
diejenigen die sich mit der Materie
intensiver beschäftigt haben wissen oder
haben vielleicht schon mal gehört dass
planmäßig Ende des Jahres zwei
Braunkohlekraftwerke von RWE jeweils 600
Megawatt stark aus dem Betrieb hätten
gehen sollen hätten gehen sollen weil
wir Ihnen heute eine Vereinbarung
vorstellen möchten dass diese
Braunkohlekraftwerke bis Ende März 24 am
Netz bleiben sollen
das ist eine spannende Entwicklung der
noch vor einem halben Jahr war
Deutschland mittendrin im colaausstieg
jetzt kann die schmutzigen
Stromproduzenten also zurück ans Netz
aber selbstverständlicher das Comeback
eine Haltbarkeitsdauer für
Steinkohlekraftwerke gilt es maximal bis
Ende März 2024 für Braunkohle soll die
Rückkehr zunächst bis zum 30 Juni 2023
befristet sein ich frage mich und sie
vielleicht zu Hause auch warum reagiert
die Politik erneut so spät und
begrenzend es war doch aus der
Industrien in den vergangenen Monaten
wiederholt die Kritik geäußert worden
dass die wieder in Betriebnahme Alter
Kohlekraftwerke zu langsam gescherr und
dementsprechend meine erste Frage an die
Fürstin mal ganz platt gefragt ist
Robert Habeck eine lahme Schnecke
also man spricht ja nicht schlecht über
andere Leute aber natürlich wäre es
besser wenn wir Kernkraftwerke hätten
weil die sind wesentlich
umweltfreundlicher aber ich habe das
Gefühl dass das die ganze Debatte
Ideologie geleitet wird und nicht
Tatsachen geleitet braun und überhaupt
Kohle ist sehr schädlich für die Umwelt
sehr schädlich ist auch wenn man große
dieselschiffe über den Ozean schippert
um uns Flüssiggas zu verkaufen ist auch
nicht ideal die windkraftfeder
verschandeln ganz Deutschland aber es
ist eben Ideologie und nicht
tatsachenbasiert das Beste für die
Umwelt sind die modernen
Atomkraftwerke die auch nicht die kann
man nicht mit Tschernobyl vergleichen
das sind ganz neue Generationen es gibt
ja mittlerweile schon kleine Kraftwerke
für jeden zu Hause also die Technologie
ist da leider nicht von Deutschland
ausgegangen in Deutschland war es ja
verboten auch darüber zu forschen aber
die Amerikaner und die Chinesen haben
fleißig weiter gemacht und es gibt ja
schon sehr sehr gute Lösungen haben Sie
Verständnis dass der Harbeck so lange
gezögert hat überhaupt Atomkraftwerke
länger laufen zu lassen ja gut das sind
die Grünen die Grünen die haben das ist
wie eine Religion also das ist die
glauben einfach und das ist das ist der
Glaube wichtiger als die Tatsache da
muss die Hose oben halten ohne
Hosenträger auch wenn sie zu groß ist
einfach der Glaube bedeutet die Hose
hält oben auch wenn ich eigentlich
Hosenträger bräuchte wie gefährlich sind
denn die Grünen für unsere Wirtschaft ja
brandgefährlich die Grünen haben uns in
einem die Energiewende war wahnsinnig
ist hat die Menschen verarmt die
Energiewende hat den den Menschen allen
Reich und Arm das gilt nur so seit 20 30
Jahren aus der Tasche gezogen und den
fehl investiert das Geld könnte man also
wie gesagt dass diese ganze die ganze
Energiewende ist gescheitert das sieht
man jetzt aber was das gekostet hat und
die Leute zu Verantwortung ziehen das
müsste man machen wird aber nicht
gemacht Herr Knabe würden sie der
Fürstin zustimmen ja ich kann das nur
unterstreichen ich habe mich ja lange
mit der DDR beschäftigt wo man auch
ständig in die Wirtschaft hinein gefunkt
hat alles verstaatlichkeit die Preise
künstlich subventioniert oder auch
aufgesetzt für Luxus sogenannte
Luxusgüter und wo das geendet hat das
wissen wir alle die DDR war Bankrott
1989 und ich habe gerade in den letzten
Tagen noch mal ein Buch zur Hand
genommen von Rolf Hinrich der
vormundschaftliche Staat heißt das und
da beschreibt ja wozu diese ständigen
ideologischen politischen Eingriffe auf
die Wirtschaft und auch auf die
Gesellschaft führt führen und nämlich
zum zur Ineffektivität und und der
träumt dann quasi davon das Land zu
befreien von dieser Plan Bürokratie von
dieser Politikerkaste und das ist dann
auch eingetreten im Herbst 89
eingestiegen mit dem ddr-vergleich das
ist ja immer ein relativ gefährlicher in
Deutschland
da sind wir denn schon in einer
Planwirtschaft also in der
Energiepolitik ziemlich nah weil das ist
keine freie Marktwirtschaft wo Waren
angeboten werden und Käufer diese waren
dann kaufen und sich auf diese Weise in
der Preis ein Bild sondern das ist zur
massiv staatlich durchsteuert durch eben
festgesetzte Steuern die auf die auf den
Energieverbrauch gelegt werden jetzt
gibt es plötzlich wieder eine Subvention
da wird Gas plötzlich viel billiger als
es wirklich kostet und dann geht das
sogar so weit dass man den Leuten nachts
die Heizung ausdreht das hat sich nicht
mal die DDR getraut sie waren ja mal
Berater auch der grün was würden Sie
denn den Grünen heute raten ja da kann
ich dir 14 nur zustimmen wirklich
pragmatisch zu entscheiden nicht
ideologisch und auch die Wirtschaft mal
machen lassen man muss da nicht in
Deutschland gibt es so diese Tendenz für
alle Probleme die man hat ist der Staat
verantwortlich und das haben die
Politiker so verinnerlicht dass sie auch
selbst dieses immer wieder jetzt
füttern sozusagen diese
Erwartungshaltung wenn der Herr Scholz
da keiner bleibt allein das ist ein
Anspruch den kann er gar nicht erfüllen
das ist absurd und das Problem was
daraus auch noch folgt ist wenn die
Politiker sagen wir sind für alles
verantwortlich und müssen alle Probleme
lösen dann sagen die Bürger auch
irgendwann mal na dann haut doch ab ihr
löst ja die Probleme nicht und das ist
die Erfahrung der DDR Herr Trabert gehen
sie mit rein ja in die Grünen Kritik
oder haben Sie einen anderen Ansatzpunkt
absolut nicht also ich finde das ist
sehr undifferenziert was gesagt wird ein
harter Vorwurf direkt unifferenziert das
ist auch und differenziert in meinen
Augen die erneuerbaren Energien das ist
die Zukunft da müssen wir investieren da
hat man viele Fehler in der
Vergangenheit gemacht man hat zu wenig
in erneuerbare Energien
investiert die Atomkraft ist nicht die
Lösung wir wissen dass Atomkraftwerke
weiterhin gefährlich sind
da hat man die Technik noch nicht bis
ins Letzte und der Kontrolle man hat das
jetzt in Frankreich gesehen wo die
Flüsse überhitzt waren wo man das wo man
gar nicht mehr die Brennstäbe
entsprechend Abkühlen konnte das ist
nicht die Zukunft und ich finde es
wirklich fatal jetzt wieder Rolle
rückwärts in die Vergangenheit nein der
Weg muss mehr in Windkraft in
Sonnenenergie in viele andere
erneuerbare Energien gehen alles andere
wird zu einer Umweltverschmutzung weiter
beitragen der Klimawandel den wir jetzt
schon haben wird damit auch unterstützt
Deutschland nicht alleine bewältigen
können wenn man sich mal anschaut ich
glaube wir tragen 0,2 dazu bei wenn man
es weltweit global sieht wenn jeder sagt
man kann das nicht allein ändern dann
wird sich überhaupt nichts ändern man
muss vorangehen man muss Akzente setzen
man muss genau hier in diesem Klima also
gegen den Klimawandel in eine
umweltfreundliche
Energieform investieren das ist die
Zukunft alles eine Angst vor einem
Blackout ich habe keine Angst vor einem
Blackout geht ihnen das auch so nein
selbstverständlich nicht aber zunächst
mal finde ich es ausgesprochen amüsant
dass sie als Sozialist sagen sie wollen
eine Rolle rückwärts vermeiden wir haben
genau
denn sie befürworten ja zum einen
Planwirtschaft und negieren zum anderen
die negativen Folgen dieser
planwirtschaftlichen Eingriffe wenn sie
sagen Wind Energie und Solarenergie
seien tatsächlich zuverlässige
Energieträger dann ist das ein objektiv
falsch es kann jeder sehen der einfach
mal versucht irgendetwas zu betreiben
wenn gerade kein Wind weht und die Sonne
nicht scheint das Problem sind die
Speicherkapazitäten das Problem ist auch
grundsätzlich auch ein Harbeck das Leute
von Themen sprechen von den sie keine
Ahnung haben die Netzlast muss ja als
Grundlast gehalten werden das heißt es
reicht nicht wenn wir da mal ein
bisschen mehr Wind und dann wieder ein
bisschen weniger haben sondern es muss
eine Grundlast geben und die Grundlast
kann entweder in der Tat über
Kernenergie funktionieren oder sie kann
über die saubersten und sichersten
Kraftwerke überhaupt jedenfalls in ihrem
Segment nämlich über den deutschen
brauen und Steinkohle funktionieren wir
haben beispielsweise Abstand die
saubersten selbstverständlich was sie
doch gerade mit einem solchen Kurs
betreiben ist aber braun und
Kohlekraftwerke muss man ja schon als
schmutzige Stromproduzent bezeichnen
also schmutziger Stromproduzent
ohne Filter wie es zum Beispiel eine
Volksrepublik China betrieben wird oder
in der DDR betrieben wurde wir haben
nicht umsonst
Schlager mit deutschen Kohlekraftwerken
über Jahrzehnte gehabt die Technologie
ist auf der ganzen Welt eingesetzt
worden wird heute auch noch genauso
gebaut beispielsweise in Afrika ja was
wir jetzt hier erreichen mit der
Deindustrialisierung denn die deutsche
Industrie lebt ja seit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg davon dass wir günstigen Strom
überall gleichermaßen zuverlässig
verfügbar machen können
einhaken weil die Strompreise waren noch
nie günstig in Deutschland die wurden
auch immer subventioniert
genau
mit Steuern belegt deswegen es war nie
also es war nie Deutschland hatte nie
als Industriestandort den Vorteil die
niedrigsten Strom und Gaspreise zu haben
sondern von jetzt künstlich hohen und
jetzt haben wir die höchsten weltweit
wir haben es geschafft die
Aluminiumindustrie im Wesentlichen aus
Deutschland zu verdrängen wie im Moment
der wesentliche Jobmotor an ganz ganz
vielen Stellen war der Automobilbau der
geht gerade auch den Bach runter an
allen Stellen ich verstehe nicht wie
Menschen glauben gerade auch in
Wirtschaftsminister glaubt wie das
eigentlich funktionieren soll denn all
das Geld das umverteilt werden muss ist
eben es wird nicht neu gedruckt es wird
auch nicht einfach als virtuelle
Geldmenge erhöht sondern es muss
erwirtschaftet werden vorausgesetzt es
soll noch ein Wert behalten und da sind
wir dann eben halt bei dem Thema der
Inflation auch die ist eine Folge dieser
desolaten planwirtschaftlichen Politik
der Zustand des industriestandes
interessiert nicht nur sie sondern auch
die Fürsten sehen uns heute dazu auch
ein Thema mitgebracht
ja also natürlich die große Frage die
man sich stellen muss als Bürger ist
sind die so Dorf oder steckt da ein Plan
dahinter meine meine Meinung ist man
kann so doof gar nicht sein da muss ein
Plan dahinter sein aber für mich sieht
es fast wirklich ich wiederhole mich es
sieht für mich aus wieder später die
späte Erfüllung des morgendau-plans man
möchte nicht und zwar habe ich eine
eigene Theorie entwickelt man hat uns ja
immer dafür kritisiert dass wir zu viel
waren nach außen verkauft haben wie wir
hereingekauft haben und durch diesen
bilanzüberschuss sind wir
schlecht angeschrieben vor allen Dingen
im anno-sächsischen Bereich wir haben
wir sparen zu viel und wir verkaufen zu
viel Ware nach draußen und das haben die
uns vorgebetet wir sollen es endlich
lassen 20 Jahre hat der deutsche kann
eben nicht anders unsere waren waren
ebenso beliebt die Menschen lieben
unsere Autos unsere Kühlschrank etc und
wir sparen halt das ist das liegt halt
am deutschen weil wir wer hat wer spart
in der Zeit der hat in der Not
deswegen werden wir jetzt bestraft unter
dem Motto wer nicht hören will muss
fühlen und
der Terroranschlag auf die Gaspipeline
ist eindeutig eine Kriegserklärung an
die deutsche Industrie an den deutschen
Bürger an uns nur das will man nicht
wahrhaben wir leiden unter kollektiven
Stockholm-Syndrom das Stockholm Syndrom
war die sind entführt worden und haben
sich dann mit ihren Entführern
angefreundet damit einfach die Zeit in
der Gefangenschaft nicht so schrecklich
ist und so kommt mir das vor bei uns
weil wir müssen endlich an deutsche
Interessen denken wir müssen an unsere
Bürger denken wir müssen dann wir müssen
uns emanzipieren und das gelingt eben
offensichtlich nicht und jetzt geht es
den Bach runter und wenn wenn er wenn
die Not groß ist aber wer den Schaden
hat braucht für den Spott nicht zu
sorgen die ganze Welt lacht über dort
also ganz konkret sie sagen wir können
nicht ohne russisches Gas
nein wir können wenn wir Atomwaffen
möchten wir kein russisches Gast aber
die Energiewende ist ja deswegen
gescheitert weil man den Russen gesagt
dass wir kaufen euch nichts mehr ab
bevor man sicher war dass man eine
Alternative hätte die Alternative kann
doch nicht sein dass wir jetzt
Flüssiggas über den See über den übers
Meer von den Amerikanern holt was ist
denn das für ein Fußabdruck das ist ja
das sind ja riesige dieseltanker wir
müssen die LNG Terminals neu bauen das
ist doch auch nicht Umwelt besser Umwelt
besser wäre die Pipeline gewesen und und
das Methangas was jetzt rausgeht das ist
anscheinend auch egal wo hat man uns
gesagt das wäre der Super-GAU viel
schlimmer als das was die die eine eine
Entscheidung will ist dass das Methangas
jetzt frei wird und in die Luft geht zu
1000 und aber tausend Kubikmetern das
wäre ihre Forderung ganz konkret
zusammengefasst an die deutsche Politik
wie man jetzt mit Putin und Russland
umgehen muss nein man muss sich vor
erste zuerst mal einen Washington wenn
das ist unser großer Bruder die die
Musik spielt den Washington das sind die
Bosse mit denen müssen wir reden vor da
müssen wir sagen Leute geraden wir
lieben euch wir sind alle Amerika
freundlich wir lieben die Amerikaner
aber hier macht ihr einen großen Fehler
ihr treibt die Russen in die Arme der
Chinesen das ist nicht gut weil die
Russen gehören eigentlich zu Europa und
die haben sich auch immer Europa
zugehörig gefühlt dieses russen-bashing
ist immer falsch gewesen man ist mit den
Russen auch nicht richtig umgegangen und
jetzt haben wir den Salat man hat die
Russen nicht an den Verhandlungstisch
gelassen man hat sie am Katzentisch
sitzen lassen das macht man nicht mit
einem Tausendjährigen Reich wir Fragen
hier einmal Herr Knabe Herr Knabe
empfinden sie das auch so dass wir
erstmal mit Amerika reden müssen und die
Russen nicht am Katzentisch sitzen
lassen dürfen nein also das
sehe ich die Fürstin Schätze und ihr
gerade zugestimmt habe möchte ich da
doch mal an herkes widersprechen
was ich da abgespielt hat in den letzten
Monaten ist aus meiner Sicht eindeutig
von einer Seite zu verantworten nämlich
von Russland und von einem Mann
insbesondere Herrn Putin der in der
Ukraine einmar ist und da seine Bomben
geworfen hat auf Zivilisten und wirklich
ein Massenmörder ist und mit so einem
Mann zu sprechen
das ist faktisch nicht mehr möglich die
hat sich selbst ins Abseits manövriert
und ich wundere mich oft über die
Naivität in Deutschland wenn man also
denkt dass wir so ein ganz normaler
Politiker mit dem man irgendwie
verhandeln könnte und Kompromisse
schließen könnte der vielleicht in der
Partei irgendwie aufgestiegen ist dann
bei Wahlen sich durchgesetzt hat nein
das ist ein knallharter KGB Mann der hat
das von der Pike auf gelernt er wollte
schon in der neunten Klasse zum KGB in
Leningrad ein Gastbeitrag geschrieben
über seine Geschichte Vergangenheit
beschäftigt was ist da so noch an
Unterlagen gibt über seine Zeit beim KGB
und da merkt man wie in das geprägt hat
Lügen täuschen irreführen langen Atem
haben um operative Kombination
durchzuführ wie sieht das genannt haben
um einen Menschen dazu zu bringen das zu
machen was man selber möchte und der
Mensch eigentlich nicht will sie sagen
wir dürfen Putin nichts glauben
also wer das tut der ist naiv der lügt
doch sozusagen das klingt jetzt ein
bisschen platt wenn er nur den Mund
aufmacht wenn sie sich da ändern am 16
Februar glaube ich war es wohl sagte
kein Mensch würde daran denken in die
Ukraine einzumarschieren eine Woche
später war er drin oder damals bei der
Krim wo er gesagt hat damit haben wir
gar nichts zu tun und ein Jahr später
lobte sich selbst dass er dass da so gut
hingekriegt hätte den Anschluss der Krim
und man das muss man wirklich sich
vergegenwärtigen diese KGB
Sozialisation die ist in der DNA dieses
Mannes das ist kein normaler Politiker
und was Amerika anbetrifft da würde ich
gerne noch einen Satz zu sagen
die Freiheit dass wir hier frei
diskutieren dürfen die haben wir den
Amerikanern zu verdanken und die
Freiheit dass wir nicht morgen selber
Opfer eines solchen Einmarsches sind
haben wir auch den Amerikanern zu
verdanken wir verteidigt uns denn wer
kann uns denn verteidigen diese
Bundeswehr mit ihren 235 Panzer wie mehr
nehmen wir mal einnehmen wir ein
Beispiel nehmen wir mal die
ostsee-pipelines nur als ein Beispiel es
ist ja noch nicht klar gesagt wer die
jetzt da wo die Sabotage war versteht
von vielen Experten es war Sabotage aber
empfinden sie das nicht dass man darüber
zu spekulieren es ist wie bei einem
Raubüberfall wenn ich nicht beweisen
kann wer der Täter ist bräuchte auch gar
nicht
spekuliert das ist Russland war es wird
ja schon überall gesagt dass es Russland
war obwohl man nicht spekulieren sollte
ich weiß nicht wer das sagt das muss man
halt ermitteln da muss man auch die Zeit
sich für nehmen das ist nicht so ganz
einfach sicherlich war unter Wasser da
sind natürlich auch die Spuren nicht so
einfach
auf jeden Fall ist das ein
Terroranschlag das stimmt mich der
Fürstin zu das ist ja offensichtlich
eindeutig so was kann man nicht so was
passiert nicht aus Zufall oder so etwas
und ich bin sehr gespannt dass wenn wir
sicherlich irgendwann alle auch erfahren
wer dafür letztlich die Verantwortung
trägt für die Toten in Butcher weiß ich
werd die Verantwortung und dieser Mann
sitzt im Kreml absolut
und was würden Sie jetzt erwidern auf
diese sagen wir mal ja sehr harsche rede
also ich würde sagen natürlich sind wir
als Bürger überfordert die an einen
Krieg zu analysieren und über einen
Krieg ist immer etwas Schreckliches und
wenn zwei sich streiten freut sich der
Dritte es ist schrecklich und wir stehen
unmittelbar vor dem Ausbruch des Dritten
Weltkriegs das müssen wir uns bewusst
machen deswegen bin ich gegen jede
weitere Eskalation auch in der Rhetorik
der Medien weil ich habe das Gefühl dass
die Generation die heute schreibt und
berichtet dass der Krieg so weit weg ist
dass sie überhaupt nicht wissen worüber
worüber mit was sie da spielen mit
welchem Feuer denn am Ende des Tages
wird werden die Geschichtsbücher werden
sagen können wer war schuld bei welcher
Konsequenz bei welchem wann wie wo was
das beurteilen dann die Historiker aber
jetzt müsste unser aller Bestreben sein
Frieden zu stiften und dass bedeutet
dass der der Krieg aufhört weil
diese Milliarden aber mir ich glaube es
sind 140 Milliarden alleine damit
könnten sie dreimal Afrika sanieren
damit könnten sie Südamerika und Afrika
sanieren wird in diesen Krieg gesteckt
und die Ukrainer sterben die ganzen
Legionäre sterben die das ganze sowieso
am am Abgrund aber wir geraten mit in
den Abgrund weil wir ja auch das
bezahlen müssen das heißt das Geld für
unsere armen und für unsere Bürger
bleibt ja gar nichts mehr übrig denn wir
müssen das Geld ja dann für die Waffen
ausgeben und für den Krieg der jetzt da
weiter druckt also in unserem Interesse
ist es jedenfalls alles zu tun um die
Politiker dazu zu bewegen egal wer
angefangen hat
aufhören zu streiten der Krieg muss
beendet werden damit wir wieder wachsen
können sonst sehe ich erstmal den
wirtschaftlichen Niedergang mit großer
Armut und und und und schrecklicher
Krise aber viel schlimmer noch der
dritte Weltkrieg und wie ein nuklearer
Winter aussieht da wird es fünf Jahre
lang nicht mehr hell da wird das
eskalieren
das wird nicht dazu kommen
putin wird sich hüten mit der NATO
sicher nachdem nach der Performance
Designer Armee da jetzt schon hingelegt
hat also das wird mit Sicherheit ihr
Wort in Gottes Ohr aber wir spielen mit
dem Feuer ich würde eine Zwischenfrage
gerne an Sie stellen Herr lute und zwar
Elm Musk der heißt ja jetzt gerade
aufgefallen das haben sie wahrscheinlich
mitbekommen medial dass er
zufriedensverhandlungen aufgerufen hat
dann auch noch auf Twitter hat abstimmen
lassen aber nehmen wir mal die Forderung
nach Friedensverhandlungen wie haben sie
das eingeschätzt von Elon Musk können
Sie die medienschädel vielleicht auch
von der Füße nachvollziehen die sie
angebracht hat also
äußert sich ja gerne sehr kontrovers
aber ist damit auch zumindest in der
Lage Themen sag mal in den medialenmarkt
zu drücken und das ist an der Stelle
meines Erachtens völlig richtig ich bin
nicht der Auffassung des Herr Butin ein
so außergewöhnlicher Typus des
Politikers ist sie sagen man darf ihm
nicht glauben er lügt ich erinnere an
Norbert Blüm Norbert Blüms die Renten
sind sicher beispielsweise oder auch an
die Situation
vergleichen kann man grundsätzlich immer
alles die Frage ist was man gleich setzt
und was man nicht gleichsetzt ich glaube
genau das wollte ich gerade als zweites
Beispiel anführen aber es gibt eine
Legion solche Beispiele in allen
Bereichen die Wahrheit ist das was als
allererstes geopfert wird im politischen
das ist doch genau das Problem also
insofern ist der Boot in erstmal nichts
anderes was wichtig ist an jeder Stelle
ist miteinander zu reden ich habe im
Parlament immer dafür geworben dass ich
an jeder einzelnen Stelle mit jedem
Kollegen egal aus welcher Fraktion ein
Dialog führe weil das unsere Aufgabe ist
zu vermitteln und letztlich dann reden
ist ja jeder bei ihnen glaube ich also
ich glaube keiner hier am Tisch würde
nein wenn ich von vorne rein sage mit
dem kann man doch nicht reden dann bin
ich natürlich nicht beim Reden dabei und
die spannende Frage ist doch noch eine
ganz andere
da können sie nicht mehr mit ihm reden
da können sie sich nur verteidigen
vollkommen in der akuten Situation
folgen aber gerade niemand mit der Waffe
auf sie zu und wenn sich Diplomaten
Treffen findet das auch ohne Waffen
statt das ist nicht die Situation im
übrigen ist es viel zu kurz gedacht was
passiert denn jetzt gut hinweg wäre wer
kommt dann Herr Katalog dann haben sie
den dritten weltkriegt
dass die Nationalisten in Russland Putin
vor sich her treiben heute schreibt
sogar die neue Züricher zeitungsweise
habe ich mich sehr gewundert weil ich
mir auch gedacht habe woher nehmen die
Amerikaner die Naivität zu glauben dass
es nach Putin besser wird wir haben in
Russland eine sehr sehr starke viel
extremere Fraktion da ist auch der
ausgeglichenste wer sagt uns denn das
nachher aber wie soll beispielsweise
wollen aber genau
wie mirand es ist nichts gekommen
Zwischenfrage ich denke dass ich alle am
Tisch einig sind das Diplomatie
selbstverständlich gut wäre wenn es
funktioniert wie würden Sie absolut wie
wenn sie denn beispielsweise auf die
scheinreferenten reagieren damit ist
Putin ja jetzt noch einen weiteren
Schritt Richtung Eskalation gegangen wir
haben ja auch ein Referendum gehabt im
Kosovo und die Kosovo Albaner haben ihre
ihre Autonomität
bekommen die sind auch von den
Amerikanern und uns anerkannt geworden
nichts anderes wollte der Donbass der
Donbass wollte gar nicht weg von der
Ukraine der donbas wollte nur weiter
russisch sprechen dürfen es wäre genauso
wenn Sie den Genf von sagen würden sie
dürfen nicht mehr französisch sprechen
von heute auf morgen
machen sie das wahrscheinlich ich weiß
nicht wer schon in der Ukraine jetzt war
ich war in der Ukraine ich war in Kiew
in Liv in Butscher in erbien in viscorod
ich habe mit den Menschen vor Ort
gesprochen ich war an dem Massengrab in
butja
das ist alles natürlich unheimlich ja
das macht betroffen die Menschen sind
betroffen die Menschen sind total
irritiert
wichtig ist dass wir nicht der Ukraine
vorzuschreiben haben was sie jetzt
verhandelt das muss die Ukraine selbst
machen ja
wichtig ist auch dass Demokratien
Demokratien unterstützen deshalb ist es
wichtig dass wir die Ukraine
unterstützen aber es muss immer das Ziel
sein dass es wieder zu einem Frieden
kommt aber das muss die Ukraine mit
Russland verhandeln und ich möchte in
dem Zusammenhang einfach auch nochmal
deutlich machen
Demokratien müssen nach außen geschützt
werden ja aber Demokratien müssen auch
im Inneren geschützt werden und das ist
ja das Thema für dass ich mich einsetze
dass gerade jetzt bei diesen fehlenden
finanziellen Ressourcen zu wenig an
Menschen gedacht wird die von Armut von
Ausgrenzung von Benachteiligung
betroffen sind und wenn ich Menschen
nicht mehr in die Mitte der Gesellschaft
zurückhole wenn ich sie nicht jetzt
unterstütze dann gehen sie für das
Modell der Demokratie verloren und das
bedeutet wir müssen Demokratien im
Inneren sichern indem wir etwas für
soziale Gerechtigkeit das Thema von
ihnen kommen wir gleich auch wir bleiben
noch einmal beim Russland den Konflikt
aber das ist mir einfach jetzt schon mal
wichtig darauf hinzuweisen sonst werden
nämlich die Menschen empfängliche für
Rechtspopulisten Rassismus und
ja danke Sarah Wagenknecht ist jetzt mit
Partei DIE LINKE das beurteil ich
überhaupt nicht ich bin parteilos ich
habe Wagenknecht ist im Gegensatz zu
ihnen bei den Linken ja ja das ist
richtig aber zu Putin noch man zur
Wahrheit gehört eben auch ja ohne
irgendetwas beschönigen zu wollen dass
die NATO dass der Westen viele
Hinweise Russlands
negiert hat das immer Genscher hat schon
Russland zugesichert die Ukraine wird
nicht in die NATO kommen wird nicht
in die West Erweiterung aufgenommen auch
andere Länder nicht aber dennoch ist das
geschehen also das war auch ein
Fehlverhalten das das rechtfertigt
nichts und diese Heuchelei jetzt die ich
auch empfinde in in dieser Diskussion
dass ein Nato-Partner der jetzt
vermittelt die Türkei dass die Türkei
einen völkerrechtswidrigen Krieg gegen
die kurten in Nordsyrien führt dass dort
in der Roger Region Krankenhäuser
zerstört werden die Infrastruktur
zerstört wird ich war in roger war ich
war in kobane und dort ist jetzt eine
Choleraepidemie eine
meningitis-epidemie und keiner kein
deutscher Politiker kümmert sich um
diese Situation wo eben auch das
Völkerrecht gebrochen wird von einem
Nato-Partner also auch müssen wir
intervenieren die Menschenrechte müssen
überall zählen die zählen für Putin aber
auch für Erdogan und für andere ein
schönes Stichwort habe ich gerne einmal
Herr Knabe Fragen sind wir da
heuchlerisch Zähne nicht die
Menschenrechte überall gleich für uns
tja das ist eine schwierige Frage
letztlich ist die Gültigkeit von
Menschenrechten abhängig von der Macht
die hinter dem jeweiligen Regime steht
wir brauchen nur nach China zu schauen
wo die Uiguren in den Lagern sitzen oder
nach Belarus wo der Herr Lukaschenko den
Schutz von Herrn Putin genießt
da werden die Menschenrechte tausendfach
verletzt das heißt ich werde nie
vergessen wie dieser Lukaschenko den
Mann da oben aus dem Flieger von Ryanair
geholt hat das ist doch unglaublich den
vom Himmel zu holen aus dem Flugzeug
raus der flog glaube ich von
Griechenland nach Finnland oder so was
und es passiert nichts weil eben davon
Angst kein Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft in
Katar stattfinden ja genau also der
Westen kann schon auch sich
positionieren muss ich positionieren ich
bin ein großer Freund für unser
Universität Universalität der
Menschenrechte ich will nur auf einen
Punkt kurz dahin weisen Herr Trabert wo
ich denke dass sie sich da auch selbst
widersprechen wenn sie sagen dass die
Ukraine über ihre eigenen Belange selbst
entscheiden können muss da beginne ich
wenn ich ganz davor dann hat sie auch
das Recht zu entscheiden wo sie sich
militärpolitisch einordnet im Westen im
Osten oder irgendwo dazwischen und das
gilt für alle diese Staaten die früher
von Russland dominiert wurden oder von
der Sowjetunion
bin auf dem Baltikum gewesen und habe
nie verstanden warum die immer gesagt
haben die EU das ist uns gar nicht so
wichtig wir wollen in die NATO ich
dachte was haben die denn davon jetzt
ist mir das klar was Sie davon haben
nämlich eine relative Sicherheit dass
Herr Putin dort nicht einmarschieren
wird weil dann eben die gesamte
verteidigungsallianz darf sie
verteidigen oder hoffentlich ein gedank
e während ich könnte ich wäre bei ihnen
ich habe nie verstanden warum man nicht
Russland auch in die NATO aufgenommen
hat dann hätten wir nämlich aber das war
der große Fehler in diesem
Kooperationsrat gehabt alle Probleme los
gewesen wir hätten einmal Knabe woran
ist es gescheitert damals mit Russland
das liegt einfach daran dass der KGB in
Russland im Jahr 2000 die Macht
übernommen hat so einfach ist das Herr
jetzchen mit Herrn Gorbatschow war das
alles zu verhandeln und das
ja also der hätte doch der gommerschaff
hätte doch auch die Panzer hier bei
ihnen hinterm Haus auffahren lassen
können 1989 heißt der demonstriert weil
es wäre doch gar kein Problem gewesen
500.000 sowjetische Soldaten waren hier
die hätten das mit Links erledigt hat er
nicht gemacht auch Jelzin hat immer
wieder diese demokratischen Prinzipien
hoch gehalten und dann
hat man ihn da unter Druck gesetzt dass
er irgendwelche Kreditkarten benutzt
hätte die ja nicht hätte benutzen dürfen
aus dem Westen und dann hat man gesagt
du musst jetzt abtreten und wir haben
hier einen der setzt das fort was du so
eigentlich vorhast nämlich den Herrn
Putin und da hat man sich eben unendlich
getäuscht und das hängt dann eben doch
lieber Herr Ludwig sie sind Frage wie
man ich rieche das wenn ich das so sagen
darf uns ist unterscheidet sie auch
prinzipiell von einem KGB Mann dass sie
Werte haben es kann sein dass sie
vielleicht auch mal Lügen was Politiker
aber es gibt Grenzen das Recht ist eine
Grenze die Menschenrechte sind eine
Grenze und diese Grenzen kennt ja Putin
nicht und hat da glauben sie ist nicht
Russland das möchte ich auch noch mal
anfangen das russische Volk ist doch
wesentlich auch differenzierter zu
bewerten nicht jeder Russe unterstützt
Putin wie mutig die Menschen jetzt auf
die Straße gehen es sind schon über
200.000 Männer durch die
teilmobilisierung geflohen quasi 100.000
nach Kasachstan 66.000 in die EU das ist
ja Proteste junge russische Soldaten im
Krieg richtig aber ich mir ist es nur
wichtig dass man auch nicht Russland
über einen Kamm schert aber gibt es auch
demokratische Bewegungen die von Putin
erstickt wurden systematisch vollkommen
richtig aber Russland ist viel bunter
multiple heterogener als ihr jetzt so
finde ich diskutiert wird aber die
Zustimmung für Vladimir Putin in
Russland ist jetzt nicht bei Null das
kann man jetzt hier auch keine freie
Presse ja woher bekommen die Menschen
die Informationen und dennoch gehen so
viele in meinen Augen viele auf die
Straße dennoch riskieren sie ihr Leben
um diesem Diktator entgegenzutreten also
da ist viel demokratisches Gespür in
diesem Volk würde ich sagen es wird aber
unterdrückt permanent unterdrückt und in
eine Diktatur sich demokratisch zu
äußern dafür sich einzusetzen das ist
halt mit dem Leben bedroht er hat das
möchte ich einfach ich möchte auch ein
Plädoyer für diese
russischen Menschen einfach hier noch
mal deutlich
äußern ja das ist mir das ist mir zu
sehr unterstreichen das dauert ich
möchte kurz eine Geschichte erzählen ich
habe
besten Freund der ist Leiter des Gulag
Museums in Moskau
und dem habe ich vor ein paar Tagen
geschrieben wenn ich irgendwie helfen
kann sagt bescheid ich hatte mich hatte
das immer vorzuschreiben ob das da lange
nicht gemacht vor mir hingeschrieben was
meinen Sie was das bei dem ausgelöst hat
der hat gesagt er hat es allen seinen
Mitarbeitern vorgelesen diese drei Sätze
per WhatsApp und
bekam plötzlich den Eindruck der fühlt
sich wie ein Aussätziger nur weil er
Russe ist keiner redet mehr mit ihm die
Kollegen von früher alle tauchen abholen
nichts mehr mit ihnen zu tun haben aber
das ist eben es gibt auch ein anderes
Russland was mit Herrn Putin nichts am
Hut hat würde ich einmal gerne Fragen
Füße in der Kontakt zwischen Russland
und Deutschland kann man ja schon sagen
ist ja abgebrochen also es funktioniert
ja kein wirklicher diplomatischer Weg
mehr müssen die deutschen Politiker
vielleicht noch mal hinfliegen weil das
überhaupt möglich wäre naja man muss so
sagen durch diese Explosion der Gouda
die Zerstörung der Gaspipeline sind
unsere Möglichkeiten jetzt doch wieder
mit Russen ins Geschäft zu kommen
vernichtet das heißt wir sind jetzt
wirklich energiepolitisch auf uns selbst
gestellt und deswegen müssen wir
natürlich zügig unsere eigenen Anlagen
wieder anschmeißen
es ist das sehr bedauerlich weil wir
natürlich als Europäer und auch wenn man
das geschichtlich betrachtet es ist ein
tausendjähriges Reich wir haben enge
Verwandtschaft mit Russland man hätte
Russland viel näher an uns anbieten
dürfen das möchten die USA aus
strategischen Gründen was ich aus USA
Sicht verstehen kann ich verstehe die
Amerikaner man möchte nicht einen
dritten Machtblock Europa und Russland
das da könnte schon und das hat sich ja
jetzt auch gezeigt durch den
Wirtschaftsaufschwung und durch die
Beziehungen die wir mit Russland an der
hätte ein selbstständiger Machtblock
entstehen können dann hätte man hätten
die Amerikaner nicht nur die Chinesen
sondern plötzlich werden auch die
Europäer selbstbewusster geworden hätte
ja auch mehr Geld gehabt und mehr mit
mit einem großen gemacht das war ja
schon vor dem Ersten Weltkrieg machen
immer gesagt der Russe hat die Rohstoffe
der deutsche die Intelligenz beides
zusammen ist unschlagbar das darf nicht
passieren
als ob wir die Russen sind genauso
intelligent wie die Ukrainer und ich
spreche jetzt über Geopolitik da ist
jetzt nicht so zwischenmenschliche
Beziehung sondern in der Geopolitik geht
es erstmal um Macht und natürlich hätte
ein starkes Deutschland
Arbeiter besser ausgebildet als der
durchschnittlich russische Arbeiter
natürlich
gerade zu tun Intelligenz gemeint mein
Gott also gerade legen sie doch nicht
jedes Wort auf die Goldwaage das ist das
ist eine Form der Diskriminierung
Differenzierung gesprochen Russland
können wir nicht über einen Kamm scheren
interessanterweise schieren wir ja jetzt
an jeder Stelle die Ukraine über einen
kamen anscheinend jeder der Ukraine ein
großer Freund dieses wir verhandeln
nicht wir wollen ein letztlich totalen
Krieg dass sie die ukrainische Präsident
gerade vertritt und das wird mit
Sicherheit auch nicht die Meinung von
100% der Ukrainer sein die Geprügel und
die müssen
noch mal wir sprechen hier von
Differenzierung das müssen wir dann
bitteschön an der anderen Seite ganz
genauso betreiben natürlich und insofern
kann man auch nicht sagen lass die doch
selbst was die Ukraine wirklich wollen
muss ja nicht zwingend das sein was der
Präsident in dieser Situation verkündet
vielleicht fehlt hier bei 8:15 Uhr
einfach der diversitybeauftragter
die Parteien abgeschafft der er hat die
Fernsehsender abgeschafft die den er
nicht haben will und er hat auch die
Parteien verboten also wie man in der
Ukraine von Demokratie sprechen kann ist
eigentlich ein Witz weil das ist ein von
Oligarchen die international vernetzt
sind geführtes Land die auch mit die
Familie beiden sitzt mit dem Boot also
da das ist natürlich gerne hier würde
ich gerne einmal Herr knabes Expertise
ganz kurz hören mit dem Vorwurf mit dem
Vorwurf ob man über die Ukraine sagen
kann dass es keine Demokratie ist also
nach meinem Eindruck hat sich die
Ukraine sehr in Richtung Demokratie
entwickelt das war vor ein paar Jahren
noch ganz anders da war noch die KGB
Leute da überall im Geheimdienst in der
Ukraine und dafür gab zwei Zäsuren das
war einmal waren die die Kundgebungen
auf dem Maidan das erste Mal und dann
gab es einen Schub der Aufarbeitung und
dann das zweite Mal 2014 der europame
protestet übrigens damals auch ja und
vor allem das hat die haben das Land
total verändert ich habe mich länger mit
der Aufarbeitung selbstkommunismus
beschäftigt und nach 2014 geht das
plötzlich los dass sie anfangen zu
feiern was ist denn mit diesen ganzen
lehnins die hier rumstehen finden Sie
das Gut in jeder Stadt Leni zu haben
sich ja auch nicht weil es ein
Massenmörder ist der da nichts verloren
hat dann haben sie angefangen diese
linienstatuen abzubauen 5000 Stück gab
es in der Ukraine wirklich in jedem Kaff
oder Sie haben die
angefangen die die Beamten zu überprüfen
ja was haben die eigentlich gemacht
früher und vor allem wer von denen seit
2014 diese Gesetze wo zum Beispiel ein R
sich neu bewerben musste um Richter sein
zu dürfen und bevor er da oder als hätte
wenn er das tat musste er seine
Einkommensverhältnisse offenlegen und
vor allem deutlich machen was hat er
verdient und was besitzt er und da gab
es eben bei vielen Richtern riesige
Unterschiede die waren steinreich um das
mal Platz zu sagen
haben
das ist ein Riesenfortschritt in
Richtung Rechtsstaat und Demokratie wir
geben in eine ganz kurze Unterbrechung
oder nachsprechen wir über die sozialen
Folgen für Deutschland bleiben Sie dran
[Musik]
also da kann ich ja ein lauter bauen und
ich ernst nehmen also genannten Experten
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren bei viertel nach acht fünf Köpfen
fünf Meinungen von jeder von uns hat ein
Thema mitgebracht dass sie bewegt ärgert
freut oder schockiert
[Musik]
so nicht Privatjet Uschi der Wetten
aber niemand von dem politischen
Parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur Freiheit diese
grünen roten stehen da und führen
hochtrabende Debatten über die Rettung
des Weltklimas und um die Füße
rumwuscheln die Ratten das Thema ist
viel zu wichtig um es nur der AFD zu
überlassen lass den Leuten noch mal den
Spaß wir sehen da etwas was eigentlich
fatal ist in der Politik bei den
Journalisten deren Job ist es doch
gerade abweichende Meinungen zu finden
und sie sollen den doch auch richtig
doof finden
vielleicht einmal kurz anders also
das sind irgendwelche anorakträger aus
Buxtehude die das Gucken so ich habe
meinen Beifall in meine lache immer
bekommen wer kümmert sich darum niemand
ditt ist bald ja man muss da ganz klar
jetzt mal auch darüber sprechen dass es
einfach nicht fair ist und nicht richtig
wo ist die Aufgabe von Journalismus
einfach die die Verlautbarung der
Politik zu hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück und kommen direkt zu der
These von Herrn Trabert ja Gedanken
heute Abend
ja es gibt schon zwei langen Zeiten
Armut Armut in einem der reichsten
Länder und der der Pandemie hat die
Armut zugenommen wir liegen jetzt bei
einer Quote von 16,6 Prozent hat der
Paritätische Wohlfahrtsverband erhoben
in diesem Jahr das sind fast 14
Millionen Menschen die von
Einkommensarmut betroffen sind
in so einem reichen Land ist das nicht
zu akzeptieren arm zu sein hier bedeutet
früher sterben zu müssen weil man das
reiste mit dem ärmsten Viertel der
Bevölkerung vergleicht sterben Frauen
viereinhalb Jahre früher
Männer achteinhalb Jahre früher also arm
zu sein bedeutet eben nicht auf
irgendwelche Konsumgüter verzichten zu
müssen sondern arm zu sein bedeutet
kränker zu sein eine höhere
depressionsrate zu haben auch eine
höhere Suizidrate mehr Herzinfarkte bis
hin zu einer geringeren Lebenserwartung
arm zu sein dass 43% aller
alleinstehenden in 88% sind das Mütter
von Armut betroffen sind wie kann es
sein dass der Familienstatus so sehr mit
Armut verbunden ist jeder dritte
paarhaushalt mit drei und mehr Kindern
ist von Einkommensarmut betroffen das
kann doch nicht sein alle Politiker
sagen immer Sie machen was gegen
Kinderarmut die Kinderarmut nimmt zu
jedes fünfte Kind ist von Armut
betroffen und das in einem reichen Land
Reichtum sind in dem zu Armut nimmt zu
und in dem Zusammenhang ist es mir
wichtig wir dürfen nicht Armut gegen
Armut ausspielen Lösungsvorschlag Armut
finden wir alles schlimm das ist ja
normal ich weiß nicht ich glaube
manchmal ist Armut auch ein ja so wie es
bei uns praktiziert wird wie man in die
Armut Gerät dass das so ein
abschreckungs vielleicht Szenario auch
ist wenn du nicht funktionierst in
dieser Leistungsgesellschaft dann wirst
du bestraft was ist die Lösung die
Lösung ist zum Beispiel der
Hartz-IV-Satz das Bürgergeld muss
mindestens um 200 Euro erhöht werden das
fordern alle Kirchen alle
wohlwartsverbände die nationale
Armutskonferenz ein mietpreisdeckel muss
es geben im Gesundheitssektor darf es
keine weitere Privatisierung
durch eine Umverteilung es muss eine
Vermögenssteuer geben in Deutschland die
berzmannstiftung hat eine Untersuchung
eine repräsentative Befragung
durchgeführt 76 Prozent der Deutschen
sind für eine Vermögenssteuer 75% sind
dafür dass der Staat mehr gegen Armut
tut ja also diese Umverteilung es muss
auch eine modifizierte Erbschaftssteuer
geben und es muss eine höhere
Einkommensteuer ja das muss modifiziert
sein ja es wird ja immer so suggeriert
dann wird man die dass das
Einfamilienhaus das noch von der Oma
geerbt hat verlieren so sehen die
modernen Einfamilienhaus
nicht in der doppelaushälfte finden Sie
dass die Steuern in Deutschland zu
niedrig sind und höhere erbschafts- und
Vermögenssteuer haben muss also ich
glaube dass wir noch sehr viel mehr
Armut sehen werden dass das Deutschland
nicht so reich ist wie er sich das
vorstellt ich sehe das bei uns wir haben
jetzt jahrelang nullzinsen gehabt man
konnte nicht sparen man der Staat hat
Geld ausgegeben wie ein Weltmeister weil
er ja am Geld ausgeben verdient hat denn
bei nullzinsen leihen wir dem Staat das
Geld für minuszinsen wir dürfen
praktisch wir zahlen den Start dafür
dass er unser Geld aufbewahrt das hat
dazu geführt dass die gesamte
Bevölkerung sich nichts mehr zurückert
legen können das heißt was früher für
uns in unserer Generation noch
selbstverständlich war dass man nach am
Arbeitsamt Leben sich ein Häuschen
gebaut hat ist völlig ausgeschlossen
kein Mensch kann sich heute ein Haus
leisten wir sind in ganz Europa die
letzten wir haben am wenigsten
Immobilienbesitz wie alle anderen
Europäer also das reiche Deutschland ist
gerade dabei zusammenzubrechen aber
Steuern betrifft aber bei Steuern
betrifft sind wir ja schon auf Platz
zwei vor uns ist noch Belgien aber
ansonsten zahlen wir Deutschen ja schon
die meisten Steuern ich will damit sagen
ich gebe ihnen wir starten die
eigentlich genug ein der Staat nimmt
genug haben aber der Staat wird weniger
einnehmen weil ja auch die Einkommen
sinken werden wenn es keine
Autoindustrie mehr gibt wenn es keine
Bankenindustrie mehr gibt wenn es keine
Chemie die Abwanderung auch von
Industriezweigen weil ja vor allen
Dingen das Schließen dann was er mit dem
passiert möchte ich gar nicht erst
wissen aber ich sage nur wenn er jetzt
schon von Armut Schweiss wird noch viel
schlimmer werden wenn sie dann wir
wollen einmal die anderen haben wir
wollen alle ihre Argumente heute Abend
noch hören nein nein nein
50% Vermögen aber das mit meiner Zeit
zum Beispiel ist schon die Vize Steuer
Weltmeister sind ist wahr das heißt der
Start im eigenen am Rhein
Vermögenssteuer Deutschland hat keine
Vermögenssteuer
ich würde gerne einmal Herrn Knabe
fragen weil ich habe gerade ich habe
gerade aufgehorcht als die von den von
den Sachen gesprochen hat die uns
bevorstehen das befürchte ich auch noch
mehr Armut gibt es Parallelen zu den
20er Jahren die Frage stelle ich mir
ganz oft
ja das wären keine schönen Aussichten
wie wir alle wissen wo die Arbeitslosen
dann in die extremen Parteien
abgewandert sind kwd und NSDAP und dann
die Straßenschlachten in Berlin
stattfanden
ich kann nur hoffen dass es nicht dazu
kommt und sie im Moment auch nicht
wirklich eine solche Eskalation weil ich
den Eindruck habe dass vieles was ja
auch hier jetzt diskutiert worden ist
ein bisschen
wie soll ich sagen Panik mache ist wir
sind ein sehr reiches Land vielleicht
das reichste Land Europas nein und
jedenfalls kein Land was unterarmut
sichtbar leidet in dem Sinne wie man das
in anderen Ländern Europas beobachtet
aber auch sichtbar in unseren Straßen ja
wenn sie durch die Großstädte laufen
nicht unbedingt daran das muss man eben
dann sich im Detail angucken wenn
Friedrichshain da Leute am Straßenrand
liegen die dort früher nicht lagen da
muss man sich fragen woher kommen die
aus Rumänien kommen nicht an die
Obdachlosen oder wie sie beschreiben
soll ich denke vor allem wo mir auch
jedes Mal wirklich schlecht wird das
sind die pfandflaschensammler und das
sind Rentner die Rente auf besser müssen
zum Beispiel wirklich das wurde dafür
eingeführt ich sammle auch manchmal
Pfandflaschen wenn ich die stehen sehe
damit sie eben von der Straße
verschwindet weil der Sinn der Sache das
finde ich hier gut das ist ein
schlechtes Beispiel finde ich
aber was die fürstins sagte diese große
Enteignung die eigentlich stattfindet
die finde ich wirklich skandalös nicht
dass man eben gibt es hier durch diese
acht Prozent Inflation jedes Jahr 8
Prozent dessen was man sich vielleicht
mühsam hat ansparen können verliert der
Stein ja auf 10% zu dass du da sagen und
das ist eben Inflation ist immer
staatlich induziert also ausgelöst ne
weil die eben über ihre Verhältnisse
gelebt haben und gerade mit
Sozialprogrammen eben viel Geld aus dem
Fenster geworfen haben ohne wirklich
zielgenau zu arbeiten deswegen finde ich
das auch mit dem Hartz IV nicht
überzeugend wenn ich das um 200 Euro
anhebe dann gibt es doch für einen
Geringverdiener überhaupt kein Anlass
mehr zur Arbeit zu nehmen
dass die so gering noch aus der
Geschichte
noch noch ein Punkt anführen die
wirklich wie soll ich sagen dynamisch
sind Gesellschaften
sind die mit großen sozialen
Unterschieden dort gibt es einen starken
Aufstiegswillen warum sind die Inder so
aufstiegsorientiert und sind jetzt in
Berlin hier überall zu sehen das hängt
mit diesem sozialgefälle zusammen und
deswegen eine Gesellschaft wo alle
gleich reich sind ist keine gute
Gesellschaft
in der Gesellschaft in der alle gleich
sind das wäre sicherlich das
schrecklichste weil sie dann endgültig
keinerlei Innovation mehr haben was wir
zunächst aber mal in dieser Debatte
vielleicht auch besser am Anfang hätten
klären sollen ist was denn eigentlich
Armut ist Armut ist definiert als ein je
nachdem nach unterschiedlichen Modellen
bestimmter Anteil also Prozentanteil des
Durchschnittseinkommens 60 Prozent das
heißt wenn Sie eine Gesellschaft haben
die sagen wir mal und eine Million Euro
im Durchschnitt verdient dann ist der
der 600.000 Euro im Jahr verdient Arm
würde man jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen es
ist also insofern natürlich schon mal
vollständige Augenwischerei von der
Reduzierung Entfernung Minderung oder
auch im übrigen auch Steigerung der
Armut zu reden denn die werden sie quasi
Definition weil es reine mathematisch
Definition ist immer gleichermaßen
vorfinden es ist letztlich für mich
nichts anderes als eine weitere Ausrede
um das Rad der sozialistisch
planwirtschaftlichen Eigenschaften noch
ein Stückchen
vielleicht lernen Sie mal was der
Unterschied ist zwischen einer
Korrelation und einer Kausalität
behaupten ohne sie zu belegen ist
natürlich kein Krankengeld Arm oder ist
der arme krank wie rum ist es richtig es
gibt den selektionseffekt der nachweist
dass chronische Krankheit zunehmend zu
einer Verarmung führen bei Erwachsenen
Armut aufwachsen getränker sind also
belehren
bitte Sie es geht genau darum dass das
Geld dass sie umverteilen wollen erstmal
erwirtschaftet werden muss wir haben
noch einen Anteil von 14% der Menschen
die Nettozahler sind in diesem Land die
das Erwirtschaften was sie umverteilen
wollen und sie und mit ihrer
Umverteilungspolitik wollen diese Leute
auch noch als Leistungsträger
ausschließen und dafür sorgen dass die
nicht mehr arbeiten nur nehmen sie denn
das Geld hier wenn Sie die Vermögen fast
nicht behalten wovon bezahlen Sie im
nächsten Jahr das Geld aber sie wollen
Antworten
nach dem feuerbeschuss auf die ja genau
dieses
diskriminierende und stigmatisierende
den Menschen gegenüber immer wieder wird
behauptet ob das Söder ist ob das sie
sind dass kein keine Motivation für
Arbeit mehr vorhanden wäre wenn ich
jetzt mehr Hartz IV bekomme einmal zeigt
das ganz klar dass die Löhne viel zu
niedrig sind die müssten höher sein denn
es ist nach dem Essen es ist
nachgewiesen um hier an der Gesellschaft
partizipieren zu können um ja das ist
noch komischer sagen er hat dann gucken
Sie doch mal den Armutsbericht des
Papierchen Wohlfahrt genau wir sind
überhaupt nicht informiert wir machen
eine Pause hier zwischen ihnen beiden
sie bekommen jetzt ihre These Herr lute
das ist nämlich nicht das will nach acht
Niveau wir sind hier immer respektvoll
zueinander deswegen kombinieren
die Menschen das macht sie depressiv
wenn so über sie gesprochen wenn jemand
sagt du musst das Arbeiten das wird mich
auch unfassbar depressiv machen hey
Leute ihre These kommt jetzt hiermit und
wir kehren zurück aufs viertel nach acht
Niveau respektvoll aber natürlich aus
streitbar sie sind dran wunderbar
respektvoll ist glaube ich in der Tat
ein gutes Stichwort und es geht um den
Respekt vor dem souverän vor dem Volk
vor dem Wähler und dem was wir am 26.09
2021 hier in Berlin erlebt haben die
sprichwörtlichen Chaos Wahlen die jetzt
ja endlich nach einem Jahr von Berliner
Verfassungsgerichtshof aufgegriffen
worden ich habe sie wenige Tage nach der
Wahl damals angefasst weil ich sagte das
entspricht nicht demokratischen
Standards das kann keinen Bestand haben
nach etwas mehr als einem Jahr hat sich
der Verfassungsgerichtshof auch
zumindest schon mal in der Tendenz dahin
gehen geäußert dass das so sein soll und
jetzt ist aus meiner Sicht auch die
spannende Frage hat Berlin eigentlich
gegenwärtig überhaupt ein normal durch
das Grundgesetz bzw legitimiertes
Parlament oder sitzen da in
Anführungszeichen scheinparlamentarium
und ich bin der Auffassung dass sowohl
der Verfassungsgerichtshof als auch der
Wahlprüfungsausschuss des Deutschen
Bundestages diese Frage ja letztlich zu
entscheiden haben zum Ergebnis kommen
müssen dass die Wahlen sowohl Bundestag
als Abgeordnetenhaus in ganz Berlin
wiederholt werden müssen und auch nicht
wie jetzt für den Bundestag in einzelnen
Wahlkreisen und das selbstverständlich
in dem Moment in dem das
Verfassungsgericht das feststellt
die Parlamentarier die dort in
Anführungszeichen dann nicht hingehören
auch auseinandertreten müssen und das
letzte legal gewählte Parlament an deren
Stelle treten muss die Frage im übrigen
was wir haben ja zwei Ebenen Landtag und
Bundestag was den Bundestag angeht wenn
der dritte Wahlkreis der Linkspartei in
zwei sind ja in Berlin gewonnen worden
bin der eine von beiden tatsächlich der
eher wackelig war neu gewählt werden
müsste würde das hier nicht nur dazu
führen dass die Linken aus dem Parlament
fallen würden weil sie die
Sonderregelung eben halt nicht mehr in
Anspruch nehmen können sondern es würde
auch dazu führen dass sich der Deutsche
Bundestag Versand verkleinert weil die
Ausgleichs und überangmandate wegfallen
werden wir hätten also genau das
erreicht was der Bundestag vorgeblich
angeblich will und ich glaube das ist
auch wiederum der Grund warum sich im
Wahlprüfungsausschuss im Moment keine
Mehrheit dafür findet wirklich gesamt
Berlin neu zu wählen wir fragen die
Frösche ob sie das Wasser im Teich
ablassen wollen
Füße wenn man das nicht so anhört ich
möchte nicht das Wort Bananenrepublik
sagen das hat zum Glück etfdp-politiker
Sebastian Scheyer gesagt deswegen kann
ich jetzt wiederholen aber wenn sie
jetzt darauf blicken sind wir in diesem
speziellen Fall eine Bananen Reparatur
ich finde es allerhand dass wir wenn
schon wir nicht wissen wie Demokratie
funktioniert dass wir uns aufschwingen
und der Ukraine erklären wollen wie
Ukraine oder den Russen erklären wollen
wie Ukraine zu funktionieren hat also es
ist schon ein Armutszeugnis dass der
Flughafen nicht fertig wird 20 Jahre
lang oder wie lang das gedauert hat und
das auch jetzt wie in Südamerika die
Wahlen nicht richtig also es ist schon
es geht auch hier geht's steil bergab
mit uns und ich muss sagen Deutschland
das reiche Deutschland das tüchtige
Deutschland bye bye Darling bye bye hier
muss ich einmal Herrn Knabe fragen ob
sie uns zum Schluss dieser Sendung der
noch etwas aufmunterndes mitgeben können
damit wir jetzt nicht aus der Sendung
aussteigen mit bye bye Deutschland das
würde mich jetzt zu sehr deprimieren für
heute Abend
ja es gibt hoffentlich Neuwahlen in
Berlin und auch auf Bundesebene und dann
werden die Karten neu gemischt das ist
ja so dass bei sind keine Neuwahlen
sondern wiederholungswahlen das führt
dazu dass dieselben Köpfe wieder
kandidieren wie im letzten Jahr und da
hat jeder die Möglichkeit jeder Wähler
das Kreuz an einer anderen Stelle zu
machen
das ist auch ihre Hoffnung sie haben das
Schlusswort wir werden nicht umhin
kommen diese Wahl wird Erholung
durchzuführen
denn wenn das einmal geschehen würde und
so durchgeht dann kann es an jeder
Stelle wiederholt werden und ich glaube
da sind wir uns auch bei allen anderen
inhaltlichen Differenzen absolut einig
Demokratie kann nur dann funktionieren
wenn sie tatsächlich bis ins letzte
Detail auch genauso gelebt wird und
jeder sie engagiert verteidigt
das war doch eine schöne Runde
unterhaltsam in Teilen etwas sehr
streitbar aber das kommt ja auch mal vor
morgen Abend geht es hier weiter ich
wünsche Ihnen einen schönen Abend und ja
vielleicht wollen Sie auch mal zu Hause
ein wenig über Politik debattieren wir
empfehlen es ihnen bis morgen und machen
Sie es gut tschüss
[Musik]